il y a trois ans le groupe
le groupe les républicains marquaient
sont profonds des accords avec la
réforme du baccalauréat général et la
disparition programmée de l'enseignement
des mathématiques au lycée voulue par
Jean-Michel Blanquer à l'époque votre
majorité refusait de voir la le déclin
du niveau global en mathématiques et le
désintérêt dans notre dans notre pays
pour cette matière c'était un contraste
total avec
la croissance quasi exponentielle des
besoins de technologie dans notre pays
pour répondre aux besoins de la société
aujourd'hui vous entreprenez un travail
de déconstruction
déconstructions de la réforme imposée
donc par votre prédécesseur en imposant
en déclarant que vous allez remettre un
enseignement de mathématiques dans le
tronc commun du lycée général
vous actez ainsi l'échec patent de la
réforme
sisnée ça nouveau une pirouette qu'on
pourrait qualifier nous sort de rotation
à 180 degrés pour rester dans le thème
je me félicite bien sûr de ce retour à
la raison un peu tardif de nature à
consolider aussi la culture scientifique
du plus grand nombre mais la mise en
œuvre pratique est encore pour le moins
confuse monsieur le ministre par exemple
disposeront nous de suffisamment de
professeurs pour assurer ses cours à la
rentrée et irez-vous jusqu'au bout du
raisonnement
en permettant de choisir un troisième
enseignement de spécialité en classe de
terminale